this week official figures are expected
to show that net migration to the UK has
hitched close to 1 million people which
would be a record high it could spell
further difficulty for the home
secretaries sowella bravaman who's
having a bit of a week of it already and
it's only Tuesday chair of the migration
advisory committee that's uh Professor
Brian Bell is with us hi professor it's
good to see you thanks for joining us on
the program this morning
um kit Malt House formerly a minister of
course uh he uh tweeted yesterday saying
students shouldn't be included in net
migration figures because they help the
economy where do you stand on that
I think that's a slightly odd
perspective work has helped the UK
economy we include those in the
statistics and the statistics are
calculated by the office of national
statistics using international standards
it's probably best not to fiddle around
with how we calculate statistics
do we calculate the statistics so
essentially any migrant who we expect
when they arrive we expect them to stay
here for a year or longer gets counted
and in in the net migration statistics
and any migrant who comes with an
expectation they'll be here for less
than a year don't get included okay what
about people who come on small boats uh
well if they apply for Asylum then
they'll be counted because Asylum
applicants are expected to stay for
longer in the year so yeah so that means
that most people who come over on a
small boat are counted in these figures
they should be but they're only a tiny
percentage absolutely of what the figure
is so what do you expect the figure to
be oh I mean you know I'm not going to
try and guess that I have no no no
Advanced knowledge but I think it's fair
to assume it's going to be significantly
higher than the 500 000 it was last time
probably most people seem to think
around seven hundred thousand or perhaps
even up to a million perhaps that would
be I'd be quite surprised if it's that
high but we'll see on Thursday
um okay
um lots of cabinet tensions about uh
foreign students I know we touched on it
there
um and whether they're good enough that
they're good money for the UK are not
and whether they're filling essential
vacancies or not and then the other the
counter argument to that is that there
are enough Brits here in order to fill
those jobs
um how do we square that Circle because
it does seem that politicians don't seem
to be able to do it well I think
students I think I think you should
think separately of students and workers
so students you know are coming here and
the vast majority of visas that are
issued to students are for the actual
student to study at University
um and the government's own strategy is
to have 600 000 International students
in the UK that's the International
Education strategy that the government
is pursuing the universities have
responded positively to that and we've
got 600 000 students so in some sense
the numbers have gone up because the
government have had strategy that says
we want more students and the
universities have done that and the
evidence is absolutely clear the
advantage to the UK economy but also to
actually to the educational experience
of British students is positive when you
have International students in the
classroom but we're an overcrowded
little island is what some people would
say well that's a question about how big
the population should be and I you know
in some sense that's a perfectly
legitimate discussion to have there
doesn't seem to be much sense about that
discussion I mean what is the right
population for the UK well David Cameron
um some time ago told us when he was in
power uh that he wanted it to be down
into the tens of thousands net migration
we're up to potentially a million that's
right I mean of course the government
doesn't formally have any more an
objective for net migration so that that
uh that number no longer exists as a
policy
um of course they never achieved that um
all the way through the 2010s the net
migration was around 200 to 250 000 and
it probably doesn't help to announce
what a an objective is for government
and then consistently fail to hit it
because I suspect that's what makes the
public think that there's no control of
immigration this number will come down
though won't it I mean we we have a lot
of people who've come in from Hong Kong
quite rightly because of the situation
their Ukraine uh as well um Afghanistan
so absolutely so um mechanically the
number will come down over time and
actually there's not most people don't
think that there's been any fundamental
change in the long run number of net
migrants who come to the UK
um and
um you know even students if you think
of students as being a big contributor
to the likely number this week and of
course most of them go home and so the
influence it's it's dangerous to focus
on the inflow of migrants and forget
that most of those people also leave and
so they don't in the end contribute to
the permanent population of the UK do
you you think that oh let me put it a
different way which of the measures that
the government is putting place at the
moment and presently using are effective
in controlling migration well in terms
of controlling migration in terms of
policies that are currently in place
um I mean There are rules for all of
these routes so it's there's no
suggestion that anyone is entering
unlawfully in any of these routes um so
you know work migration for example
There are rules about how much you have
to earn what sort of skills you have to
have before you can come in the
government can of course tweak those
rules if they want to increase the
number of migrants who come in or they
reduce them
um but I think the different question I
suppose is what if you wanted to reduce
net migration in the long run you will
have to change policy because otherwise
it will settle down to around 200 250
000. I suppose the point I'm getting at
and it's what we touched on early on in
the interview is the fact that we hear
about stop the boats all the time and
this is what the Prime Minister wants to
do but that number is an absolute drop
in the bucket compared to actual people
who are coming over legally yeah well at
the moment the government hasn't said
What It Wants net migration to be so if
it is comfortable with net migration in
the long run being about quarter of a
million then it probably doesn't need to
change policy at all and it just needs
to recognize that the temporary factors
we've talked about are causing an
increase at the moment but that will
um slowly fade away if they don't think
250 000 is acceptable then they will
need to change policy to reduce that
long run number okay it's fascinating
stuff Professor we'll see when the
figures are out Thursday Thursday lovely
it's good to see